the best motion picture of the year it
all comes down to these five wonderful
films the nominees are
Brokeback Mountain Diana asana and James
Sheamus producers
Capote Caroline Barron William Vince and
Michael ohoven producers crash Paul
Haggis Kathy Shulman of course producers
good night and good luck
Brad Heslov producer
Munich Kathleen Kennedy Steven Spielberg
Barry Mandel producers
and the Oscar goes to crash
crash was nominated for six Academy
Awards tonight ridden free for film
editing Original Screenplay and Best
Motion Picture
Oh No
I didn't say
my god oh thank you so so much what an
amazing night thank you to all the
members of the Academy for embrace my
name every single one
thanks for embracing our film about love
and about tolerance about truth thank
you to the people all around the world
who have been touched by this message
and we are humbled by the other nominees
in this category you have made this year
one of the most breathtaking and
stunning maverick years in American
cinema thank you
we'd like to thank Lionsgate boy to do a
job Jon Feltheimer and everyone in every
office of that building and we would not
be here today if it were not for Tom
Orenburg and for Sarah Greenberg thank
you thank you also to our finance ears
and Erie Murray encore Boleyn marina
graça club yari to our producers our
partners Mark Harris and Bob yari and
Don Cheadle and Bobby maresco Thank You
Don Cheadle our partner we wish you
could be here with us tonight thank you
everybody thank you to my husband to my
wife into all of our family
Oh